hi there a little bit of fog out on the
water here
[Music]
today i want to talk about
you know the the sort of the world we
live in
where
languages teach themselves the language
is the teacher this is going to be the
subject of my
talk
at the
global polyglot conference which is an
online event
and i'm going to leave a link here in
the description box it starts on friday
and i have prepared a presentation i'm
not going to give you my presentation
but i do talk about this phenomenon that
we're surrounded by so much of the
language we can access the language i'm
not dependent as i was 50 years ago on
my teacher to find me things that might
interest me in fact most of the teachers
didn't care what interested me the
learner oh and by the way
if you like these videos please
subscribe you can
you know tap on the bell or click on the
bell to get notifications
and
please come to link and learn languages
the way i do we're happy to have
obviously more members and of course
that's where i spend my time learning
languages uh you may know that i've been
working this is my 90-day challenge on
arabic i put up a video sort of month
one end of month one video in arabic and
i will be doing another one
at the end of month two at the end of
october and another one a third one at
the end of november
i'm doing these videos to show that i am
actually learning to speak although my
main
goal is to achieve better comprehension
of
podcasts on subjects of interest to me
because i know that if i continue to
engage with this material i will improve
and if i am better at understanding then
i does you know it's not as painstaking
to struggle through them looking up
words as i'm you know forced to do
in link now
right now in link my um you know
unknown words percentage which used to
be 30 40 is down to 15 so it's easier
than it used to be however i want it to
be even easier i would like to see that
unknown words percentage go down to
below 10. so and you'll notice by the
way i have on
green and red because we were going to
have our polyglot conference in mexico
cholula mexico we couldn't do it because
of the covid and so we will be going
there next year okay the following year
we have some people preparing many
stories in nahuatl which is a mexican
language just to let you know we'll be
mentioning that again at the conference
but it's interesting you know
you know people ask me like so why do
you still learn languages here i am by
the way
october the 8th i was 75. so at the age
of 75 why are you still learning
languages
of course the answer is
that with the languages you discover
people you discover more about people
you discover how they are different and
you discover how they are the same and i
was just thinking as i happened to put
on a green and a red you know a green at
least a red golf shirt and a green
little uh vest here and that's the
colors of mexico it's also the colors of
italy yeah the white in there it's the
colors of iran it's the colors of
portugal and i'm sure there's others
that i've left out of it and one of the
interesting things about flags is that
these colors repeat so red white and
blue we have the us we have britain we
have russia
holland again i'm going from memory
there are undoubtedly others croatia
serbia um so red white and blue repeats
uh you know red and white uh austria
canada switzerland uh
i think denmark
oh i forgot norway for the red white and
blue so it's just it's a silly little
thing but
a lot of things that we as humans do and
enjoy they repeat everywhere we go with
the enjoyment of food the enjoyment of
good company
um and of course all of this becomes
accessible with language and what's
different today is
you don't necessarily have to just sit
in the classroom you don't necessarily
have to depend on a teacher you can find
it everywhere you can find it in
podcasts you can find it in some of the
many stories that some of our members
have created for other learners and
which we're now creating in nahuatl but
which exist in 30 some odd languages and
i've often said that i would like to see
more people help create this kind of
content especially the intermediate
content so that people can move more
easily from say the many stories to
something like the podcast
and i have done interviews with
you know
trying to remember
the names but hugo and other uh french
podcasters you'll see them in my list of
videos in french who are putting out
this kind of comprehensible and
interesting uh content yet which isn't
as difficult as say
a podcast on politics or on science or
something else which is kind of the next
level of difficulty
and i have also mentioned that the
availability of automatic transcription
like happy
scribe
makes a lot of this material accessible
like it never was so the combination of
the internet and mp3 players and happy
scribe and podcasts and google translate
and the whole range of things
is making the language the teacher for
those people who are motivated enough to
take advantage so
please check out our polyglot conference
which is virtual online starting on
friday
you'll go to the website you'll get much
more information i'm going to leave a
link to the website here
and that's essentially what i wanted to
say today
and hopefully some of you will take in
some of the presentations that are going
to be essentially recorded videos as i
understand it
i'm not fully
you know uh oh faye as to whether
they're going to be some interaction
between the speakers and other
participants but if you go to the
website you'll find out all about it so
that's what i have to say today bye for
now
[Music]